hello everyone welcome to today's
keynote presentation the science of
biofilm control with antimicrobial
agents and Judea Rock elaborate and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
library comm is a leading scientific
social networking site and we are proud
to bring you this interactive web
seminar for more information visit us at
lab roots com here's how this
presentation works we want to hear from
you questions comments and even answers
can be submitted via the green Q&A
button the lower left of your screen
we'll try to get everyone but if not
we'll make sure to follow up with you by
email you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you can't hear or see this
presentation properly let us know by
clicking on the support button at the
top right for the Q&A button in the
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Phil Stewart dr.
Stewart is a professor of chemical and
biological engineering at the Center for
biofilm engineering at Montana State
University he received his BS degree in
1982 from Rice University an MS in 1985
and PhD in 1988 from Stanford University
all in tenable engineering after
finishing his doctoral studies he was a
NATO postdoctoral fellow at the austere
jacquimo new in Paris France and a
senior chemical engineer at Bechtel
environmental in San Francisco
California he joined the faculty of
chemical engineering at Montana State in
1991 dr. Stuart has also been integrally
involved with the Center for wild film
engineering since his arrival on Montana
State campus serving as director from
2005 to 2015
dr. Stuart's research focuses on each
control of detrimental microbial
biofilms he has authored or co-authored
more than 150 technical publications and
has directed projects for 18 industrial
sponsors he is the recipient of an NSF
career
award and has been honored at Montana
State University with both of that
institutions top faculty awards for
excellence in research and scholarship I
will now turn it over to dr. Stewart
thank you Judy
and this is Phil Stewart at the Center
for biofilm engineering it's my pleasure
to have this opportunity to visit with
you about microbial biofilms and their
control with antimicrobial agents going
to take a science-based look at the
physics chemistry and biology of the
interaction of a biocide or an
antibiotic with a biofilm today I just
realized that there's an error on my
title slide it should say former
director Center for biofilm engineering
I just stepped out of that role after 10
years as director here we have a new
director Mathu seals who's leading the
center now as of July 1st I'm back to
being a professor and researcher and
teacher just down the hall still
involved in the center with the people
here that I enjoy working with so just
to warm up here would like to show you a
pictures of a couple of biofilms to
remind us of what they're made of this
is if you're out for a little hike of
this summer and cross a stream and slip
on us and slimy rock that might have
been a biofilm like this one probably a
mixture of bacteria and micro algae
growing together on a on a in a
symbiotic relationship on that rock and
I know we're not going to be trying to
clean rocks with antimicrobials but I
just want to put this up to remind us
all that muffin formation is a is a
ubiquitous natural process it's not
something that's been cooked up just to
deal with troubles in industrial or
medical systems this is an ancient very
robust microbial survival strategy in
natural
varmints here's a here is a look inside
a urinary catheter and that deposit that
you see in the lumen of the catheter is
a mixture of bacteria extracellular
polymeric substances that the microbes
have secreted the glue of the of the
biofilm and this also contains a mineral
phase so the microbial activity here
facilitates the precipitation of a
mineral called struvite and the biofilm
then essentially has a little rocks in
it the urologist call this deposit and
incrustation and it can become so
extensive that it includes the catheter
prevents it from performing its basic
plumbing function of drain urine and can
sometimes then trigger a urinary tract
infection like other device related
infections these respond very poorly to
antimicrobial chemotherapy once they're
set up these bathrooms are very
difficult to eradicate and here's a
cutaway view of an oilfield pipeline
that crusty deposit that you see on the
inside of this pipe is again a mixture
of biofilm and corrosion products again
abiotic materials that have become
trapped in the sticky matrix of the
biofilm they use a lot of biocides
in the oil patch to control problems
associated with fouling corrosion
souring the generation of hydrogen
sulfide and they're all microbial
biofilm phenomenon so just a few
examples and to set the stage for the
discussion here I have just want to
share with you a recently published data
from a literature review that I've done
and what I've done here is to go to the
literature and pull
out numbers from in vitro laboratory
investigations of biofilm susceptibility
and these are from a very wide variety
of model systems that you know represent
systems all the way from cooling water
to dental plaque
different kinds of microorganisms
different kinds of biocides but the
design that you're that you're seeing
the data that you're seeing here is
often the same experimental designs the
idea is that investigators set up some
sort of Baffin reactor and grow the
biofilm to different stages or ages
maybe a day three days a week at each
time point that they looked at they
challenged the biofilm with the same
antimicrobial dose and and and then
measure the killing that is achieved in
the biofilm and that's that's what the
log reduction is on the y-axis here and
what you see in all of these studies is
the same trend that as a biofilm ages it
becomes less susceptible to
antimicrobial control we can even attach
a half-life to this acquisition of
Tolerance it happens over a time scale
of a few days and so this is just a
backdrop to trying to delve now a little
deeper into why biofilms are hard to
kill and and what phenomena are
important in this interaction between an
antimicrobial and the microbes in a
biofilm so these are the four topics
that I want to touch on diffusion is
going to be important in the penetration
of an antimicrobial agent into a biofilm
the flow of water around the biofilm and
the mechanics of the biome itself are
important in the process of biofilm or
remove
a key and still rather poorly understood
aspect of bathroom control and then we
have the biology ranging from the whole
cell physiology kind of where things are
growing and where they're not growing
all the way down to the genetic level
and we're starting to see in the
literature some of the clues about which
genes and sets of genes are important in
protecting a biofilm from antimicrobial
so we'll take a look at that too let's
start first with this question of
diffusion and penetration this is the
most intuitive explanation for why a
baffle is hard to kill that the drug or
the disinfectant just doesn't get in and
what I'd like to do here is show you a
movie made in the lab of a an antibiotic
working its way into a big staff biofilm
so this is a flow cell system continuous
system in which the bottom grows in a
little glass tube that has a square
cross-section and we can bring a
microscope objective down to the top
wall of that tube and using confocal
scanning laser microscopy look right
inside the biofilm that's going in there
here's an example of what a
Staphylococcus epidermidis laughin can
look like in this system this is a
relatively low magnification
transmission image here that the tube is
about a millimeter across the black
blotches are large dense clusters of
staph biofilm hanging off the ceiling or
sidewall of the tube if we go inside one
of those clusters at much higher
magnification here by transmission
electron microscopy now you can actually
see the individual staff cells these
little black spheroids and this faintly
stained grayish material in between the
cells again that's the gel like
extracellular matrix that is the glue
holding the structure together
so here's here's daptomycin this was the
antibiotic we're going to look at some
manufacturing but Cuba's pharmaceuticals
and the chemists at Cuba's attached a
green fluorophore to it so that we can
see it in the confocal microscope the
structure of the molecule is not
particularly important except to
register this as a rather large
antibiotic and a bit sticky okay so
here's how the experiment works we find
a cluster like this one and switch to
the green fluorescent channel it's dark
to start with because we haven't put the
drug in so there's nothing to see here
but the cluster is still there it's
right about there and in a moment when
we play the video what you're going to
see it's a six minute time-lapse
sequence under flowing conditions flows
from left to right so the daptomycin
which is going to appear green here is
going to come in from the left surround
this cell cluster and move right into
the center of it in in a matter of just
a few minutes all right you're going to
see it move in on the upstream and
downstream edges of the cluster
symmetrically and that's telling us that
this is really once we're inside the
bathroom is really a diffusion process
so now we'll play that video and watch
this experiment
you
you
okay so the take-home message from this
experiment is that this large antibiotic
has accessed the interior of this giant
staph bhavam cluster in a matter of a
few minutes and certainly in the context
of antibiotic chemotherapy where we're
measuring the duration in in days this
delay of a couple of minutes can't help
us understand why this biofilm is hard
to kill the drug gets in let's look at
another technique for measuring
penetration this one uses micro
electrodes very fine needle shaped
sensors that are engineered to detect a
particular chemical species in this case
it's going to be hydrogen peroxide and
in this experiment that we'll show you
we're going to actually have two
electrodes one is positioned down at the
base of the biofilm just a few microns
off the stainless steel slide that is
attached to you and we leave it there
the second one is positioned up in the
bulk fluid that's flowing over the
biofilm and it's fixed so now when we
run a hydrogen peroxide solution into
this open-topped flow cell we can record
in real time what's being delivered to
the top of the biofilm and what's making
it down to the bottom of the bottom
here's an example of that this is
hydrogen peroxide concentration versus
time the red trace is the signal from
the electrode up in the bulk fluid so at
time zero we run in a solution of
nominally 50 milli molar hydrogen
peroxide and the black trace that's
getting along the x-axis is the signal
from this lower electrode down at the
bottom of the bathroom in other words
the hydro peroxide is not showing up
down at the base of the bathroom at
about 3,200 seconds in this experiment
we pulled that lower electrode back up
into the fluid just to make sure it's
working we get a spike in signal the
electrode is working the hydrogen
peroxide is not penetrating well how can
that be I just finished telling you
adapte Meissen molecular weight 1,600
penetrate penetrates a monster staph
biofilm in a matter of a few minutes and
now I'm telling you that hydrogen
peroxide molecular weight 34 fails to
penetrate this is actually a little bit
thinner biofilm in the better part of an
hour and the explanation is is that
these bacterias happens to be a pseudo
monad but like many many other microbes
these bacteria make enzymes catalyzes
that degrade and completely neutralized
hydrogen peroxide the biofilm is like a
reactive sponge it's soaking up hydrogen
peroxide out in the surface layers of
the biofilm faster than it can diffuse
in so this reaction diffusion
interaction only happens when there's a
when there's a rapid enough reaction to
set this up with daptomycin there's no
such speedy neutralization of the drug
and so it moves into the biofilm
just according to the dictates of
thiking diffusion but when we have a
neutralizing reaction fast neutralizing
reaction in the system as we do for
hydrogen peroxide as we do for halogens
perhaps this is a very powerful
protective mechanism and I'm not trying
to turn your stomach's with these
equations but I do want you to register
that there's a rigorous physical
chemical basis as a classic chemical
engineering problem to analyze the
penetration of a reacting solute into a
biofilm okay let's take a look at the
biofilm and the flow around it and how
that can lead to biofilm removal and
unfortunately the video that goes with a
slide is not working so I'll just
describe for you
the upshot here this is actually not our
work this comes from a beautiful German
website called the virtual album of
fluid motion and if you want to see some
cool videos of computational fluid
dynamics this is the place to go and
what they simulated in this case is the
flow down a conduit that has a rigid
bumps on the wall so the little black
protrusions into the flow field the blue
here are our bumps that and what I liked
about this is that it looks something
like the capillary system that we just
looked at where these where these bumps
would actually be for me by custer's
about them and when you when you look at
the simulation what you see visually is
very complex flow patterns the flow is
swirling around these bumps there's
recirculation there's instabilities and
it's immediately clear that the fluid is
applying forces to these bumps that if
their favorite or biofilm would it could
cause them to to move over or even break
and we don't get to see that most of the
time water is clear and we don't
appreciate just how much is going on in
that fluid phase here's another way that
we can watch this interaction between
the flow and the biofilm we're back in
the capillary flow cell that we've been
looking at with a little bit different
staining technique so here what we're
going to do is load the bacterial cells
up with a green fluorescent dye prior to
the antimicrobial treatment the dye is
trapped inside the cell as long as the
cell membrane is intact but if the
animaker bial damages the membrane makes
it leaky then we can see that in the
loss of green color right so fkin green
color leaks out we know the
antimicrobial has arrived and actually
damaged a membrane here's an
illustration this is a very heavily
fouled section of one of these capillary
tubes
what you're looking at is an overlay of
the transmission image in grayscale
showing
where there's biomass that's the black
and then a much thinner confocal slice
showing you where the bacteria have been
loaded up with this green dye and now
we're going to run in a quaternary
ammonium compound very common industrial
biocide and consumer product
disinfectant this is an hour long
exposure under continuous flow flows
from left to right and what you'll see
here when this movie is played is a very
distinct spatial temporal pattern of
green fluorescence loss look for the
biofilm wiggling around in the flow this
is a nice reminder that these are
rubbery viscoelastic structures and I
think we'll watch this experiment now
and play that video for you
you
okay
it looks like that didn't play very well
but what you would have seen here is a
fair bit of the green color leak out and
the biofilm moving around but remaining
intact in fact it looks like the quat
doesn't remove a single cell the whole
structure is still there after the
biocide treatment and that is you know a
very important distinction for us that
the that the process of killing or
disinfection and removal or detachment
are distinct they have different physics
chemistry biology different timescales
they're both important in a Buffum
control a problem but at this point we
still know a lot less about removal and
we do about disinfection let's look at
another example here same system now
we're coming in with a very aggressive
concentration of free chlorine 50
milligrams per liter at neutral pH so a
mixture of hypochlorous acid and
hypochlorite if this video will play for
us what you're going to see here is a
progressive loss of green color that
happens from the outside in and I'd ask
you to watch for the process here what
it looks like is that the chlorine only
knocks out the green color in a thin
zone around the periphery of the cell
cluster but it does kind of burn its way
in the other thing that you'll see here
is some erosion of biomass and we
there's very few treatments that
actually give us this but what it looks
like again is that the chlorine is
attacking the mechanical integrity of
the matrix around the edges of the
cluster weakening it and then allowing
the flow to strip that weakened material
often so this cluster shrinks during the
hour-long treatment and let's let's see
if this movie will
run for us now
you
you
okay.i I think you got a glimpse of that
I hope you could tell that the cluster
shrank that there's still a little green
left in the center of it at the end of
the time what it looks like here is the
chlorine doesn't penetrate very well and
we've done a lot of work on that one
it's the exact same reaction diffusion
limitation of penetration that we saw
with hydrogen peroxide but on the other
hand taurine doesn't have a removal
effect it does actually weaken the
material and allow some of it to be
removed here's a completely different
flow cell and a different imaging
modality this is a staff a different
strain of Staph that contains a green
fluorescent protein and in this view
we're looking down onto the biofilm from
above imagine that you're tethered in
the in the fluid over the biofilm and
we're using the confocal to take a stack
of images and kind of reconstruct a 3d
view of this so in this experiment we're
going to run a solution of sodium
bicarbonate baking soda into the flow
cell and this is we don't think this is
a has antimicrobial properties I don't
think it kills bacteria but you will see
a dramatic effect on the biofilm so when
this movie plays you'll see the biofilm
kind of twitching around in the flow and
then partway in when the bicarbonate
actually hits the biofilm it very
swiftly weakens this material and you'll
see it deform and be stripped off the
surface by the prevailing fluid flow so
we're not changing the flow rate here
the hydrodynamic stay the same but
there's something changing in the
strength of the biofilm by this rather
innocuous sounding treatment and let's
take a look at this experiment
you
great I want to emphasize that baking
soda is not a magic solution to every
biofilm problem there's other biofilms
that are completely unperturbed by
sodium bicarbonate there's what we think
is that there's something in this
particular strain of Staph aureus
something in the matrix that's
hydrolyzed by the modest pH increase and
as that you know material breaks down
the biofilm is weakened and and the
fluid flow is able to just strip that
right off the surface this just intended
to open the door to thinking about
alternative paths to by often control
that don't have to rely just on killing
germs we can now target the matrix of
the biofilm and of course down the road
it's attractive to imagine combinations
of these strategies that might be
synergistic while we're thinking about
biofilm material properties I'd like to
share with you some work by our
collaborators ray house all ski and his
postdocs region former postdoc region
our garwal at the University of
Minnesota
what Shri John did was to actually
measure a material property the failure
strength of bacterial biofilm the
bathroom here is the dark vertical
stripe in the center of this image it's
stuck to it's grown on a coupon this to
the left and then he came in with a
curved micropipette and grabbed hold of
the biofilm by suction and once he had a
hold of it the coupon was retracted so
in the in this video you're going to see
the coupon and biofilm moved to the left
and the biofilm gets a increasing force
applied to it and eventually will break
and from that video
he was tree John was able to extract an
estimate of the finger strength of the
bathroom so
let's watch this experiment this is
probably just a 30 second 30 seconds in
real time so here's the video
you
you
so I think you can appreciate from that
just how remarkably elastic this
particular biofilm is and how it's hard
to get it off the surface in this case
here's a look at some composite
measurements from that kind of system
this happens to be for Pseudomonas
aeruginosa this is a histogram of the
failure strength on the on the x-axis
plotted on a log scale and what I want
you to get the fish strengths in tasca
it is a Pascal so Newton's per meter
squared force per area per
cross-sectional area what I want you to
see here is that this property spans -
almost three orders of magnitude in
other words sometimes when sri John
comes down and grabs hold of the
bathroom and pulls on it it falls out
very easily and other times when he
grabs hold of it this would be up at the
right end of the plot here it's
extremely tenacious is to really apply a
lot of force to get it to come off and
what I think this is a clue telling us
that biofilm material properties like
other like the chemical and biological
properties of biofilms can be very
heterogeneous at the micro scale a lot
of variety and that that variety just is
one of the ways that these systems are
so robust the biofilm really has it both
ways here the weakly attached pieces can
release from the surface and go
downstream colonize new locations the
very firmly attached pieces can hold on
and survive you know huge physical
challenges and they're going to be there
tomorrow to you know own that Pete
that patch of substratum okay let's move
into the biology and think about the
physiology of the organisms within a
biofilm we've done a lot of work
developing and applying techniques to
actually go inside a biofilm at the
micro scale and visualize and quantify
patterns of activity here's one example
this is a Pseudomonas aeruginosa biofilm
also in the capillary flow cell where
we've used a reporter gene trick to
light up regions of active protein
synthesis those are the green the red is
just a counter stain to show you where
there's where there's biomass
independent of its activity and what we
see is in the larger clusters that the
protein synthetic activity localizes in
a thin zone around the periphery of the
cell cluster right this is this is where
the biofilm adjoins the medium which is
the source of nutrients and oxygen so
this makes sense but what we what we
would hypothesize here is that many of
these red bacteria in the center of the
of this cluster are still viable
they're just inactive they just don't
have everything they need to be rapidly
synthesizing protein and they're shut
down and in that less active state
they're likely to be less susceptible to
many different kinds of antimicrobial
challenges this is a recurrent theme in
mature biofilm systems let me just show
you a little bit more data to reinforce
what's going on here here's here's a
measurement also made with a micro
electrode this one is a detecting oxygen
in which we're showing that within about
50 microns into the biofilm most of the
oxygen is gone so there's a very steep
chemical gradient here bacteria up at
the top of the biofilm are aspiring and
consuming oxygen as it diffuses in
and this creates this sort of oxygen
shadow underneath that for one thing can
help us understand how a biofilm and an
aerated water can Harbor strict
anaerobes or how a biofilm is likely to
exhibit stratified activity patterns
there's regions of very different oxygen
concentration in this case here's
another another example this is a
Klebsiella biofilm frozen cross section
sliced through the biome the substratum
would have been down along the bottom
here nutrients flowing over the top and
the the colors here without going into
the details of the method reveal the
relative growth rate of the cells so red
or orange red cells are growing rapidly
and yellow or green region to indicate
putative regions of slow or no growth
and so what you see here is a band of
activity that tracks the biofilm
nutrient interface where the biofilm is
then and not too dense
in between these first and second
clusters for example the whole biofilm
can be active but in the three thicker
spots underneath we have these regions
where we could speculate that the
bacteria are growing slowly or actually
have stopped growing and this is you can
see this is an old result what we're
doing now with mathematician tan Yu
Jiang is to simulate this and again it's
a reaction diffusion interaction now
we're not dealing with an antimicrobial
we're dealing with the growth limiting
nutrient which in this case is glucose
and the colorful pattern here is one of
the simulations showing you the
predicted distribution of glucose
glucose is being delivered along that
top boundary red corresponding the
higher concentrations blue to lower
concentrations and here we are able to
predict that indeed we anticipate
regions of
Minister depleted glucose underneath
these three cell clusters and if we take
that glucose concentration map and just
plug it into a mono growth kinetic
expression for their growth of this
organism we can predict patterns of
specific growth rate that's what the top
panel here is this is the simulated
growth rate in units per hour put on an
orange green scale so it matches the
experimental result and the take-home
message here is that that we can we can
do a pretty nice job of simulating these
patterns of activity that go from all
the way from very rapidly growing close
to the maximum specific growth rate of
the organism to essentially zero growth
rate and again it's these regions of
green where the organism have slowed way
down that are going to be difficult to
target with an antibiotic for example
okay all right let's take this one level
or a couple levels further down all the
way to thinking about specific genes
that could be involved in the protection
of a biofilm and like to start with a
little explanation of the persister
hypothesis and a simulation again using
a models is one of the tools that that
we use here at the Center for valve
engineering quite a bit the model will
be a 3d cellular automata model of
Baphomet emulation that captures this
mechanism of persister formation so
here's how that works the idea is that
most of the bacteria in the bathroom are
in this green state on the left where
they're growing they're synthesizing the
matrix of the bottom as long as there's
nutrients available locally and they're
propagating the genome these cells are
also relatively vulnerable to an
antimicrobial challenge every once in a
while one of these green cells
differentiates
through the expression of specific genes
and gene products but we're not going to
try to name right now into a protected
persister cell which we color purple
here these are likely also a non growing
state but these cells are highly
protected from antimicrobial challenge
they can survive the challenge and then
if long as they can you know kind of
revert or resuscitate they can reseed
the community after that challenge all
right let's look at this simulation here
you're looking at a patch of substratum
and gray that is randomly colonized
initially with twenty little micro
colonies of biofilm and when we watch
this video you'll see these little
clusters begin to grow and expand and
they start to coalesce if you put your
nose up to the screen you might be able
to see a purple dot here and there so
what we've done is to code in a random
probability at every time step that a
green cell will convert into a per
sister state and those become those are
coded purple and is likely this is a
random probability that the persister
will revert back to a growing green
state and we've picked those two
probabilities so that at any time about
one percent of the population is in the
persister state so you'll see the purple
dots come and go to ephemeral but
there's always a few around and when the
anima crow bial treatment comes in at
200 hours in this simulation it's going
to kill most of the green cells and they
turn red when they die any cell turns
red when it dies that the anima curve is
only in there for 12 hours
and what happens post treatment is that
the persisters germinate and reseed
little clonal pockets of regrowth and
very quickly this whole biofilm regrows
you're also going to see towards the end
a big fluffing event or
Bassem comes off but there'll be a
little bit of life left in the chunk of
laughing that's still attached so let's
watch this simulation in the video
that's next
you
okay so this is a simulation it doesn't
prove anything
but it does tell us that if this
division of labor strategy of putting a
subpopulation into a protected State
actually happens in in the real biofilms
in microorganisms it's a it is indeed a
very powerful protective mechanism can
help us understand why these systems
tenten - whether in industrial or
medical tend to regrow pretty quickly
after an antimicrobial treatment I'm
going to finish by showing you a little
bit of work from our own lab on trying
to get a handle on which genes are
involved in the protection of a biofilm
this is this boffin was grown in the
drip flow reactor that you see here and
we can show this is going to be a
Pseudomonas three-day-old Pseudomonas
aeruginosa biofilm like the other
bathrooms that we investigate we see
stratified activity here regions of
activity and inactivity the oxygen
profile that we saw a few slides ago is
from this same system so we know there's
an oxygen gradient in this biofilm and
what we've done here is to harvest o
first let me just show you that indeed
these bottoms are less susceptible than
free-floating bacteria so these are kill
assays this is a log reduction on the on
the y-axis measure killing comparing
planktonic and biofilm cultures of the
same string of Pseudomonas to two
different antibiotics and so with with
the intact bath on the red bars we get
about a log reduction with this 12 hour
exposure whereas the planktonic cells we
get about something like a four log
reduction if we take a biofilm prior to
antibiotic treatment and break it apart
disperse it and and resuspend the cells
and
the antibiotic those cells are
susceptible T to the agent so this is a
reversible probably a reversible
phenotypic mechanism here alright and
what we've done then is to harvest
messenger RNA from the biofilm so we're
in the middle here and compare biofilm
to planktonic gene expression patterns
using microarrays and today I'm just
going to focus on the 340 genes that we
see that are more highly expressed in
the bathroom compared to planktonic they
give us a clue about what the biofilm is
doing that's different from a suspended
cell 340 is is something like five
percent of the of the genes in the
organism and I'm not going to go through
all 340 genes with you what we're going
to do oh well this is this you could
call this a fishing expedition but the
great thing about microwaves is you know
we are going to catch some fish and by
kind of examining which fish we catch we
we do learn something okay the strategy
we've taken here to analyzing that that
list of 340 genes is to go to the
literature and compile independent lists
of genes that are associated with
particular protective mechanisms for
example the first line here refers to
drug efflux pumps a very common
important mechanism of antibiotic
resistance these are busy
pumps in the cell membrane that actually
spit or vomit the the drug out of the
cell and what we can do now is is ask by
comparing this list of drug e flips pump
genes with our 340 genes that are up in
the bottom are those genes already
turned on in a biofilm even before the
antibiotic got there and we're just
looking for overlap between
the two lists of genes and we can do a
statistical test to convince ourselves
that the overlap is you know more than
just chance when we do that for the drug
efflux pump genes for 39 genes there
there's very little overlap the large
p-value here is telling us that we
didn't really catch anything on that
mechanism same thing here for iron
limitation we don't see any signature
for our limitation in this particular
biofilm neither for heat shock neither
for genes that have been associated with
ciprofloxacin sensitivity in planktonic
cells we do see a few of the genes
associated with homoserine lactone
quorum sensing but what what is
overwhelmingly convincing is that
there's large overlap between our 340
biofilm expressed genes and genes
associated with oxygen limitation and
with a stationary phase or growth arrest
so actually this is this is very
gratifying to me I already told you that
we measured a chemical gradient and
auction so we know auction is limiting
in part of this biofilm and here from
the transcriptome the bacteria are
telling us that indeed you know we're as
fixating down here we can't get enough
auction we can we can infer that from
the genes that they've induced
likewise we see genes associated with
slowdown and growth and entry into a
kind of limited or non growing State so
the next step here which I'm racing
through but is to take mutants in genes
regulatory genes associated with this
either the hypoxia response or the
stationary phase growth arrest response
grow by um with that mutant strain and
ask if it is
more susceptible than the wild-type so
here's here's that data this is for this
is for ciprofloxacin so with the wild
type strain the first line here the
first row we get just a little less than
and then a 1 log reduction with our
standard cipro treatment and if we take
an NR mutant so this is a mutant
deficient in the response to hypoxia
it's a low oxygen that mutant forms it
still forms a biofilm but the biofilm
actually is more susceptible to the drug
treatment so we get now to a half log R
addiction and we get the we see the same
behavior with an rpoS mutant rpoS is a
stationary phase Sigma factor again a
regulatory gene that's that comes into
play when the bacteria exit exponential
growth and enter stationary phase and
these are POS mutants form a form of
great balance as you little thicker than
the wild-type biofilm that is quite a
bit more susceptible almost a three log
reduction on the rpoS mutant and
similarly this release boaty double
mutant is a deficient in the stringent
response another mechanism by which
bacteria deal with growth arrest and
again that means is also less
susceptible to - I'm sorry more
susceptible than the wild-type just to
show you that not every mutant we try
falls over dead here here's another one
mvf R we see that a lot of genes
regulated by mvf are in the biofilm but
the mutant is actually not statistically
significantly more susceptible and the
wild-type so in this case what what it
looks like is that there are parallel or
possibly overlapping stress responses
and there may be more than these three
in the middle that I've talked about
here that do contribute to the
protection of this biofilm
from ciprofloxacin here's the results
for tobramycin and interestingly none of
these mutants have a phenotype for
tobramycin so it
seemed to matter what genes are on or
off for tobramycin that's still hard to
kill so I think we think there's a
different protective mechanism that work
for tobramycin or contributing to
tribulation protection we can talk about
that more all right just to recap here
are the four phenomena that we've talked
about that are involved in the
interaction of an antimicrobial agent
with biofilm and a summary of the
take-home points here first that the
penetration of a biocide or an
antibiotic into a biofilm actually for
that matter any any cell you into a
biome is governed by a reaction
diffusion interaction it's for those
antimicrobials that are subject to a
wrap a neutralizing reaction that we can
see a breakdown in penetration also told
you that removal is distinct from
killing and that the mechanics and flow
of fluid around the biofilm matter in
the removal process we know that
biofilms are criss-crossed by
concentration gradients and metabolic
substrates and products and for this
reason biofilms Harbor amazing
physiological heterogeneity in the same
small you know space we can have
bacteria rapidly growing and then not
too far away ones that are dormant and
we're beginning to see in the literature
clues about the specific genes and
pathways that are important in or that
contribute to the protection of a
biofilm and what it looks like to me at
this point is that there are multiple
different stress responses and possibly
pathways of differentiation into a per
sister state that can can contribute to
reduce biofilm tolerance
thank you so much for your attention and
if you'd like to learn more about biomes
I invite you to find the website for the
Center for bottom engineering or come up
to Montana and visit us sometime there's
a lot of blue sky and puffy bacteria
shaped clouds sailing overhead thank you
and I think we move now to the question
and answer session thank you for that
presentation dr. Stewart yes we want to
get right to your questions and input so
here's a reminder how to let us know
what have to say questions etc can be
submitted via the Q&A button lower left
we will try to get all of you but if not
we will be sure to follow up after the
broadcast our first question is from Cal
from the University of Pittsburgh who
asks what method you use to successfully
extract high-quality RNA from biofilm
okay you're you're asking the engineer
about the biology question so this is
this is a collaboration with Mike
Franklin and her microbiology department
here who could give you a much better
answer so I can't off the top of my head
even tell you the specifics of the
method the work that I just mentioned to
you has been recently published in
antimicrobial agents and chemotherapy
but this is actually fairly routine now
so lots of people are able to extract
good-quality
RNA from biofilms and induce you know
RNA seek or microarrays okay cue go from
after Estonia can horizontal transfer of
antibiotic resistant genes be assessed
in biofilm certainly it can be and
people have done that and today and
really talk you know is talking more
about tolerance rather than than
resistance but it's clear that you know
a plasma that has a resistance gene on
it can move
from one cell to another and a biofilm
and there's been some elegant
demonstrations that using for example
agreement or you know fluorescent
protein marker that moves from one cell
to another and you can actually see that
transfer you know in the new cell lights
up when it requires that plasmid so
certainly a horizontal gene transfer it
does can't happen in the biofilm lots of
great questions coming in we have time
for just one more it is from Miranda
from the University of Perugia and she
asks I'm wondering if antimicrobial
agents targeting the biofilm matrix
although being efficacious and
eradicating the biofilm itself could be
harmful in terms of favoring the
detachment of live bacteria from the
biofilm and their migration to other
sites where they can in turn form
against biofilm excellent question and
absolutely something that we need to pay
attention to so the issue here is that
if we pour an agent into a system
whether it's a cooling water system or
somebody's bloodstream that causes a
massive dispersal a detachment event
that could could cause problems
downstream certainly releasing a burst
of bacteria into the bloodstream viable
bacteria might not be a good thing at
all so I think in many of these
situations it will be important to have
an antibiotic or another animal herb
you'll in in the mix to be able to
control those released bacteria the
released microorganisms and that you
know the good news is is that we know
when when the bacteria become dispersed
and planktonic that they're they're
going to be much easier to control I
also think that there may be scenarios
were dispersing the bacteria we won't
have to do anything else for example in
the body the body's own defenses will
just mop up those and and dispatch those
dispersed to planktonic cells and the
problem will be solved hey we do have
time for another one for you I'm
Christopher from Utah Division of
Wildlife Resources fishery the
Experiment Station asked what effect you
antiquorum sensing agents have on a
mature biofilm so there's been a huge
interest in this potential strategy of
jamming the cell-cell communication
process in in a biofilm as a way of an
alternative strategy for controlling it
and well despite years have worked by
really smart people there's we haven't
seen any of those quorum sensing
inhibitors commercialize so this is
another one where it looks like blocking
quorum sensing on its own is probably
not enough to you know just have a
biofilm disappear it may reduce blocking
quorum sensing there's some evidence
that that can reduce or knock down the
defenses of the bathroom and make it
more susceptible to an antimicrobial
challenge but right now I'm not seeing
you know quorum sensing blockers that
you know just cause a bottom to go away
on the room but there's there's more
possibilities there the restaurant we're
not there yet if we weren't able to
speak directly with you today we'll be
sure to follow up with you thank you for
taking part we want to thank today's
presenter as well for joining us here at
lab is calm the leading scientific
social networking site for more
information visit us at
www.gigaprojector.com she couldn't take
part in today's broadcast see you next
time bye
you